COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY MAY SEVENTH
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER. PLEASE
BE ADVISED AND AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEEDING
IS BEING MADE SAUCEPAN
TELEVISED.
AHMED SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO.
YEAH.
CERVANTES HERE FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON CARE MAYES SHARE.
THIS AREA PRESIDENT
SO I WATCHED SOME OF THEM
WALDRON. HERE WE HAVE PART WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSIDER GENDER SO MOVED AND
MOVED BY. A MISTER. RACE YES
AND.
THANKS SORT OF OUR HOUSE.
ARAMBULA.
MATTER SURGERIES AND ALL THE.
COOLEY ABOUT.
OUR AYE COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE CERVANTES
AYE CERVANTES AYE FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON
AYE MAYES AYE MAYES AYE NOSE
AREA.
THIS AREA AND I SALAS AYE SALAS
AYE WALDRON. WALDRON AYE.
MEASURES PASSED MOST OF PASSED
AND THIS RULES WHEN IS A DRUG
THAT BERMAN